let's go to uh democratic texas congress
and henry cuellar what he makes of all
of this congressman always good to have
you
this this rage that i hear from many of
in your party sir about the the the
treatment of these uh migrants who are
finding their way to places like
martha's vineyard in new york and
possibly now delaware uh
i don't remember that same outrage when
there were ten times as many uh
being started all over the country all
points north oftentimes in the middle of
the night with no word of warning or a
heads up to local officials i don't
remember a peep about that
well you know certainly one of the
things that we see that when something
happens in your own backyard
then it becomes a
problem itself
what we are looking at is there is some
theater involved here it has got the
attention that's what we're talking
about right now but i'm more interested
in practical solutions and one of the
practical solutions is that we got to
give our men and women of homeland
border patrol eyes uh cbp the power
where they can enforce the repercussions
that is you treat people with respect
and then at the end of the day if they
don't qualify then you have to deport
them and we're not showing any people
being deported when was the last time
neil that you had images of people
returning back like secretary jake
johnson under obama did we're not seeing
anything all we see is six to eight
thousand people a day coming in into the
united states but i don't hear the rage
congress i know you're trying to deal
with this you've led a bipartisan effort
with fellow republicans to try to get
something hammered out but i don't
remember concerns raised by the welfare
of those coming in from the border uh
until those coming from that border
ended up in these cities and towns
yeah i mean without a doubt that's the
truth i mean for many years as you know
over the years i've been talking about
the border saying hey uh you know it's
okay to listen to immigration activists
but who's listening to the men and women
in green who's listening to the border
communities and this humanitarian relief
the fema i actually started this program
in 2014 and then in 2017 we reformed it
that money has been there and it took me
years
to get this done and now it's happening
in some of the people's backyard and
also oh we're gonna have more money
we're gonna add money nobody was
listening to the border communities for
years and now that it's happening in
their own backyard they're they're you
know they're they're talking about it
and i'll say one more thing by the way
they might get two three buses a day in
laredo just the loreto sector there's
nine sectors in laredo every day laredo
sector sends out 21 to 26 buses a day
21 to 26 buses they're either run by ice
or they're run by the ngo and guess
who's paying for all this the taxpayers
you know i've been listening the
comments out of mayors in these
sanctuary cities congressman who again
and again referred to our mistreatment
in texas
of uh
immigrants they never say illegal
immigrants but but they're illegal and
i'm wondering if they don't look at them
as illegal
we'll we'll never make progress dealing
with this because that's not the problem
it's not illegal immigration we just
have a lot of immigrants who want to be
here and some are being denied the
american dream does that trouble you
well you know look the there are laws in
the book saying somebody comes into the
united states without the right uh
way then it's illegal it's illegal point
that's it no it's no butts about so the
two million plus you've gone through the
borders sir i just want to be very clear
about this we're not dealing with
immigrants we're dealing with people who
are legally trying to enter this country
now that would be called
illegal immigration
right
yeah i mean look if somebody follows the
process and they're asking for asylum
then that's one thing but the there are
people that either are asking for asylum
or
or
uh they're trying to evade the border
patrol and as uh the story was you know
the reported before this you know in
just in two years uh with getaways and
uh and the people once we finished the
fiscal year we're gonna talk about
somewhere between 4.5 to uh to 4.9
million individuals that have come to
the border if you call that a secure
border i don't know what it is so
congressman president seemed to draw a
distinction today
that some of them are coming in or
coming up places like venezuela and he
seemed to animate here that they're
they're they're looking to escape a
horrible place uh but but that he seemed
to draw a distinction there in a couple
of other countries do you
look uh again there are some people that
will have legitimate uh asylum claims
but most people don't if you have a
hundred people that ask for asylum in
front of uh you put them in front of an
immigration judge 88 to 90 are going to
be rejected
only 10 to 12 so why are we he seemed to
be he seemed to be
hitting congress i'm sorry to keep
jumping on this but he seemed to be
getting that if you're from venezuela
you of course are trying to escape
you're trying to get asylum uh and so
you of course are going to be here and
allowed to stay here that's how i read
it am i wrong
well
and keep in mind people from venezuela
cuba are only one
it's a small percentage you got people
from not only mexico central america but
you got people from all over the world
saudi arabia india bangladesh china
russia name the country there's over 60
countries that are represented so
venezuela has only one part but there
are so many people from across the world
that have already figured this out you
come through the southern border guess
what there's a low speed bump
and then you come across
congressman claire thank you very much i
did want to get your take on some of
these unusual takes i'm hearing on those
trying to get into this country hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now